to president fond alliance press
conference ahead of the g20 summit and
of course 26
the president will make introductory
remarks and then we will take a few
questions president you have the floor
thank you very much and
good afternoon from my side
indeed we have two very important
summits
ahead of us as you know the g20 summit
in rome this weekend and then back to
back cop26
and i would like to report um how we're
seeing the development of these two
summits and what our position is there
so let me start with g20
g20 is
the meeting of the 20 largest most
advanced economies in the world so in
general we will have a 360 degree view
on the world but i want to focus on the
three main topics where the most
discussion will be on and that is the
pandemic
or how to end the pandemic that is the
question of global economic recovery
and that is the question of climate
change
so first of all i'm tackling the
pandemic
here i think
the main deliverable at the beginning to
set the stage is the fact that the g20
will commit
to the goal that we want to have 70
of the global population fully
vaccinated by mid next year
this is an ambitious goal
but we fully support this goal
if you look at the european union side
what we are contributing
we have so far in the last 11 months
exported over 1.2 billion
doses of vaccines
to 150 countries
we have
delivered close to 880 million doses to
the european people so we have made good
on the promise that at least every
second dose that is produced
in the european union will be shipped
abroad even it's even more if you see
1.2 billion exported and 880 million
delivered to the european people and we
will keep on going with that export we
have looked into the next year
and we expect more than 3.5 billion
doses of vaccines
to be produced in the european union and
of course a majority of those will be
shipped abroad
on top of the exports we will as a
european union team europe the
commission and the member states
donate more than 500 million doses of
vaccines till mid next year
i expect more pledges from the member
states to come
i am also aware that the member states
have faced some obstacles what the
delivery of these
pledged doses is concerned so we are
trying to address the issues with the
member states and of course with the
vaccine producers to speed up the
deliveries
then there is a second topic this is the
one the vaccines the exports the
donations then there's a second topic
underpinning our goal that we want to
get better with vaccinating the world
and this is the mid and long term the
g20 leaders will call for an increasing
manufacturing capacities and delivery in
developing countries and here the focus
is on the mrna technologies as you know
this is a project that is very dear to
my heart
europe is investing more than one
billion euros
in africa for exactly this purpose
our common goal is that we really bring
the mrna technology to the african
continent so that it is being produced
there for that with our african partners
we are convening the pharmaceutical
companies of course
but also foundations
the private sector
we are working on
the conducive regulatory environment
with the african cdc
building up an african medicines agency
and of course within financial
institutions like the european
investment bank
and so far
we have made good progress
with senegal rwanda and south africa
indeed i think it's two days ago now
that bayern tech
signed an agreement
with rwanda and senegal so this is
moving forward quite nicely and we are
now considering to have also such a
cooperation with other african countries
like ghana egypt morocco nigeria or
kenya
this is nothing for the very short term
this is more for the mid and long term
but um i fully support the the goal the
african countries do have
and that is to be more independent in
producing their own vaccines
as of today it is so that if you look at
all the vaccines that are administered
in africa not only speaking of covet 19
but also the other vaccines
only one percent is produced in africa
and 99 are imported the goal is that
africa sets itself to happen 20 40
60
of the vaccines administered in africa
also produced in africa and i think this
is feasible
now besides the vaccines
my second point on health in the g20 is
pandemic preparedness
as you know we took important
commitments in may at the global health
summit
what we do need is a strong who to
better prepare the world for potentially
a next pandemic
and we need to move forward from the ad
hoc responses we have right now more to
more structural responses and more
structural uh
structures that are more permanent to
establish
and this lead needs leaders attention
therefore one important aspect is to
bridge the gap that we see between
finance and health
that is in the g20 to bring together
finance minister and health ministers
and of course that requires adequate
funding so to underpin that structure
with the necessary funding
so that we can
prepare better the world for
cross-border health threats future
cross-border health threats and also
mainly to strengthen health care systems
that
have proven not to have enough
resilience during this pandemic i must
say we're not there yet
in the negotiations to g20 there are
different views on how to do this
but i hope that we will find an
agreement mainly with the background of
the experience of the pandemic we have
right now
so far for the health part
in the g20
the second subject we will discuss in
rome will be the global recovery
and given that the largest economies sit
around the table
this is also the place to discuss
how we can ensure a robust economic
recovery we will also discuss how supply
chains
in the economy in the global economy
have been struggling to keep up with
rapidly rising demand
and in addition i believe we will
discuss how the high energy prices
if sustained
could pose a threat
to the global economic recovery and what
measures could be taken
and finally on the recovery part
g20 is of course also the place to
discuss the global minimum tax
when we are repairing our economies
right now and when we are investing in
the recovery
we will and have to pay attention to
fairness and the global tax agreement we
have found does exactly that
the g20 will agree on a global tax
reform i think this is historical
and afterwards it's going to be about
implementation
we stand ready to implement it quickly
from the eu side we will already make a
proposal for implementation
on the minimum effective tax rate before
the end of this year
and we expect the system to be globally
in pri in place by 2022.
now the third topic that we will discuss
at g20 with a lot of emphasis will be
climate change
as i said we have the
20 most advanced economies around the
table
these 20 largest economies also
represent 80
of the emissions worldwide
and therefore we have
a special responsibility to act
uh the commitments that will be taken in
rome on climate change will somehow be
also of course a pacemaker for the crop
26.
what we need is first of all leadership
we need leadership for credible
commitments for decarbonization to reach
the goal of
net zero mid-century
but we also need sufficient commitments
to really cut the emissions this decade
science is very clear on that
science tells us it's urgent
we are not on track right now
it's man-made climate change so because
it's man-made we can do something but we
have to act we have to better deliver
and only that would enable us to keep
within the goal to limit the global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
the second important topic not only in
g20 but then also in cop 26 will be
climate finance
as you know we have promised
to deliver year by year 100 billion
dollars to the least developed and most
vulnerable countries concerning climate
change adaptation and mitigation
and
we need to deliver that there are if we
look at the statistics now finally
encouraging developments according to
the latest report by the german and the
canadian governments
we will exceed the 100 billion dollars
target in 2023
so we are making progress but i think we
have to try harder
we should look at providing the 100
billion dollars already next year there
is still a small gap and i think we
should put a lot of emphasis in trying
to close that gap
as you know the european union and its
member states are already the largest
contributor to climate finance with more
than 25 billion dollars per year
i expect also this number
to get up uh to go up in the next days
and
um i pledged on top a top-up of five
billion dollars till 2027
expecting others also to increase the
ambition
and this leads me directly finally to
cop 26.
indeed cop 26 is mainly resting on three
pillars the one pillar is about ambition
so the big question
do we get significant commitments to cut
the emissions to actually allow us to
stay well below 2 degrees celsius
and close to the 1.5 degrees of global
warming
if we look at the latest un
emissions gaap report
that shows that currently the ndcs do
not
meet the global goals of paris of the
paris agreement
and thus we are still on a very
dangerous course of more than two
degrees celsius of global warming this
is worrisome and we have to get better
there
the second pillar is about climate
finance i was just referring to that and
the third pillar is about the rulebook
book on international carbon markets
so
we need to make progress on these three
points mainly during cop26 it is the
ambition of cutting more emissions now
it is the climate finance for the least
developed and most vulnerable countries
and it is completing the rule book
and i expect the negotiators to do the
utmost that we really advance in those
three topics
finally a look on europe
europe is on track
to become the first climate neutral
country and in the world by 2050.
we have a new number that shows
something interesting because we have
already reduced
our emissions
by more than 31 percent compared to 1990
while growing our economy by 60 percent
and i think this is an encouraging
message
that shows you can cut emissions
and prosper
you can reduce the greenhouse grass
emissions you can produce cleaner
healthier
and more sustainable
while growing your economy and this is
exactly what we have to show to the
world and what we have to show to our
people and our people are expecting us
to progress on that
i think it's good to see that many more
countries have signed up to net zero mid
century
but what we also need now is not only
targets but we need very concrete plans
and immediate action on the ground
really to show in detail how we're going
to get to reach those targets within
this decades
the longer we wait the more expensive it
will become and therefore it's about
action now
finally
um as always we will launch a number of
new actions
at
cop26
together with president biden i will
launch the global methane pledge
under this pledge we commit to reducing
methane emissions by at least 30
by 2030
methane if you look at the greenhouse
gas emissions greenhouse gases is the
lowest hanging fruit fruit
it is
80 times more warming than co2 so
there's urgent need to do something
and there is a lot we can do
and therefore i'm glad that by now 60
countries
joined us so far and of course we're
encouraging others to join this ambition
the second initiative
will be that i will announce a financial
contribution of 1 billion euro
to the global forest fledge
that includes includes 250 million euros
to the congo basin
you know that protecting our forests
worldwide is a priority for the european
union the first are our first are our
best allies in fighting climate change
so we need really to protect them
the third initiative we will launch is
on innovation
innovation is key
to fight climate change and to progress
into a circular economy
with clean
for producing procedures and more
sustainable
consumption
and therefore future technologies will
be the key to help cut emissions
we want to demonstrate
and this is the core of this initiative
that investment in green innovations
pays off
so in glasgow i will launch together
with bill gates a program called
breakthrough energy catalyst
we join forces there
the aim is to prove that if you have a
breakthrough innovation of course at the
very beginning it's a bit more expensive
but if we relieve that green premium we
help this
innovation
to be more
to be more fast and being market
feasible and to scale up better at the
markets such as for example
innovation in clean hydrogen sustainable
aviation fuels carbon storage
carbon capture and the energy storage
such to name
the four fields where we will be
investing in
last but not least the
fifth initiative that we will presumably
start we're still working on it
that is joining the us the uk germany
france and the european union
to launch together with south africa a
just energy transition partnership
the idea is
that
the countries
support south africa
to phase out of coal faster and to go
earlier and faster into developing
renewables
we're still working on that but
i am confident that we are going to
launch this new proposal and then this
partnership
could become a template on how to
support just transitions around the
globe with sponsoring countries and
countries that have to move on faster in
the just transition
that was
quite a bit sorry for being a bit long
but it's important four days ahead of us
and back to you donna
thank you very much president i will
take a few questions
alternating between the room and the
colleagues connected online and there
are many of them there irini first go
ahead
thank you donna i would like to ask what
are eu's expectations for cope26 and
what do you believe is going to be
different this time thank you
our expectations are that we really step
up in the ambition
to cut emissions this decade
we have to get better with the ndcs
more concrete
in the deliverables because we have to
act now science is very clear in telling
us you're not on track you have to get
better
global warming is progressing faster
than we expected
there is a way out this is through
innovation you can do it and
be better and more more ambitious on
that the second point is
if we want to be successful
we have to
as developed countries we have to
support the developing countries and the
most vulnerable countries this is about
climate finance this is a question of
credibility
and of solidarity worldwide
and indeed the third topic is the rule
book very complicated but very important
because it is about the rules
how are we measuring uh successes or
steps forward in cutting emissions as
you know there are a lot of percentages
a lot of dates floating around
and how are we for example measuring the
offsetting of some emissions so that you
have accountability that you have a
system that is science-based and
accountable for for real progress and
therefore
really to show the world that we are
getting better in fighting climate
change
what is different
um
well
paris set
out the vision
and that was and is incredibly important
but now it's gonna be concrete
it is not only about goals and targets
but now it has to be about very concrete
detailed steps and a road map
within this decade
to make a credible change a crucial
change that is absolutely necessary
and therefore this is very detailed this
time
but it's also a moment of truth
thank you george she's next
uh good afternoon jorge with bloomberg
here um it's just a full up to the the
previous question because
even though the talks are still ongoing
the expectations are not very high if we
look at the national country
contributions are not enough to keep
global warming below two percent and the
financial contributions are falling
short of what we need to be achieved so
having this in mind what is your best
hope for
the cop 26
and then also if you expect a deal on
article 6 carbon offset trading rule
book
during the climate summit
so indeed the starting point is not a
good one
and in therefore it's also a moment of
truth to science tells us very clearly
and the reports tell us very clearly
you're not where you want to be in
fighting climate change you have to get
better
and the second message is
it's not a question of 30 40 years it's
now it's this decade where we have to
get better otherwise we reach we risk to
reach irreversible tipping points
and then
um it is very clear that this is a high
ambition with leadership where we have
to go into cop26 it's encouraging the
negotiators
really to set the bar high
it's not about the question who is going
to be
more advanced than
others it's a question of survival of
mankind on this planet it's the question
of how we gonna leave this world behind
to our children it's a question about
are we gonna now do the necessary steps
or are we running more and more
into extreme weather situation as we've
seen this summer they will increase and
thus also block more and more resources
in
in fixing the damages
instead of being able in investing into
the innovation that is necessary to
really get better
thank you very much i will now go
towards the colleagues connected online
by patrizia has her hand up first on the
list
thank you dana from the floor and good
afternoon president
um i would like to understand what you
expect from the g20 and how do you
assess your cooperation with premier
draghi
uh during the italian
g20 presidency thank you
yes the the cooperation uh with madrid
and is excellent
um i want to recall that we have the g20
health summit that was really setting
the foundation for uh what we're
discussing now at the leaders summit
in rome
so an excellent preparation many many
months of intensive work
and without this good preparation would
not have been able to start now in the
intensive talks concerning the health
part but of course there's also the very
important part uh concerning the
recovery
and um setting the stage for the cop 26
in climate
as you know the final negotiations are
still very much ongoing so as we speak
there is progress
therefore we will we will see what
finally will be the result on sunday
evening
thank you very much second on my list
remotely is anscar
could you please connect him
mr president on climate change
the commission presented already in july
proposals to deliver its
30 targets
however the member states do not seem to
have a strong interest in dealing
quickly with
this issue so um for example the fit45
package was not even mentioned in the
recent european council conclusions and
we hear that intensive discussions could
not begin until next summer
do you think that things are progressive
progressing uh quickly enough and is
there really enough european leadership
before the g20 summit and the cop thank
you
so if you look at the global stage
europe is the front runner
without any question
and
we do not only have
our very ambitious goals for example
cutting at least 55
of the greenhouse gas emissions till
2030 but we have by now a detailed road
map that we are working on we are the
first worldwide to have that
so if you look at the global scene
europe is as i said the front runner but
of course that should not reduce the
pressure internally in the european
union that climate makes on us or puts
on us
to act quickly and to show
that through innovation and through
change you're able to move forward to a
more sustainable cleaner hopefully than
totally circular economy
and
it is also i think our duty and our
responsibility to move forward fast
because then we can prove also to the
world that
growing sustainably and cutting emission
goes hand in hand now what the actual
situation is concerned
we also have the climate law so 27
member states the european parliament
all have
committed themselves with the climate
law that is very clear and now we have
to deliver
thank you very much
thank you dana marty sokowski polish tv
tv 24 madam president may ask you about
poland and yesterday's decision of the
european court of justice uh do you
think that one million in europe per day
is enough to convince poland to suspend
the disciplinary chamber
or what if it's not enough
and the second about the recovery fund
so far you've visited you've been to 22
countries to uh hand over the decision
could you picture yourself in warsaw
handing over the
yellow folder with the decision
accepting funds for poland incoming
quicks thank you
i could and can picture myself in every
member states state handing over
the envelope for
the
next generation eu
and
the preconditions are very clear for
that to happen we have agreed and this
is in the regulation to have investment
and reform
and the reforms are linked to the
european semester and the
country-specific recommendations
there is a long-standing
country-specific recommendation for
poland that is the independence of the
judiciary
and thus i've always been very clear
we want to put into
that recurrent resilience plan
a clear commitment
to dismantle the disciplinary chamber
to end or reform the disciplinary regime
and to start a process to reinstall the
judges
this happens to be also of course
embedded in the overall ruling of the
european court of justice this is a
long-standing process
therefore there is consistency
in what we are asking for i think it is
doable
i hope
that we will reach an agreement but the
reform part is conditional
thank you very much
this completes the press conference of
today the president is on her way to
rome she will need to fly
very shortly but see you very soon thank
you
come on
you